- [Voiceover] All right Kim,
so we left off in I guess,
early-mid 1861, you have
Lincoln gets inagurated,
Fort Sumter which is kind
of the first real conflict
of the war, if not the first major battle.
Lincoln forms his volunteer army, and then
the rest of the southern
states secede, four more
states secede.
- [Kim] Right.
- [Voiceover] And then what
was the first major conflict?
- [Kim] So the first
major conflict comes after
a number of months.
There are a couple of little
skirmishes here and there,
but nothing super large
until about 60,000 troops
meet outside of Manassas, Virginia,
at a place called Bull Run.
An interesting fact, I think, is that
Union armies and
Confederate armies actually
named battles different
things, if you've ever been
confused about this.
The Union armies tended
to name battles after
bodies of water, whereas
the Confederate armies
tended to name them by nearby towns.
So if you've ever heard
the Battle of Manassas
and the Battle of Bull Run,
they're the same thing,
it's just the Union officers
are talking about this creek,
Bull Run, whereas the
Confederates are talking about
the town nearby.
- [Voiceover] I see, and the 60,000 troops
between the two of them.
- [Kim] Right.
So they meet, and this is very
close to Washington, D.C.,
so much so that people go
out and they bring picnics
to watch this battle.
- [Voiceover] They think it's
going to be entertaining.
- [Kim] Yeah, they think
it's going to be like
a football game.
And it is not like a football game.
It is a gigantic battle,
800 people die that day,
which doesn't sound like a lot to us, but
it was the most deadly battle
ever in American history
up until that point.
So it's a Confederate victory,
which is very surprising
to the Union, because they
think that they have such
superior forces that this
is really going to be
a very short war.
And this is a quick rebellion, in 90 days
we're going to be able to, you know,
suppress this rebellion and that'll be it.
But Bull Run is really the first sign that
this is going to be a major war.
It's not going to be quick
and it is going to be
very deadly.
- [Voiceover] This was July of...
- [Both] 1861.
- [Voiceover] Okay, so now
it's clear to both sides,
especially, I guess you
could say the North,
that this is not going to be a short war.
So they need to prepare.
How are they approaching this?
- [Kim] Well, so both
sides have some advantages
and disadvantages.
For the South, they have some of the same
advantages that the United
States would have had
during the war for independence.
They have home court
advantage, we could say,
which is that they know
the territory very well
and also there's a real
incentive for people to
protect their homes, right.
You're gonna care more
about a war that's happening
on your property than a
war that's gonna happen
very far away.
The other advantage that they have is
just really, really terrific
military leadership.
So they have Robert E. Lee,
who is
widely considered the
greatest general of his era.
He's truly a military genius.
He, in fact, was offered a
commission in the Union army
but when Virginia seceded,
he went with Virginia.
He preferred his home state.
So he is a terrific general.
The Union is gonna really
struggle to come up with
the kind of military
leadership that the South has.
- [Voiceover] Who is in
charge of the Union or the
Northern armies?
You said, the United States Army.
- [Kim] The United States Army.
The first general that
Lincoln puts in charge is
George B. McClellan.
This is problematic for a lot of reasons.
One is that George
McClellan is a Democrat,
so he doesn't agree
politically with Lincoln.
I think he would have
preferred peace, in fact
in 1864 he runs against
Lincoln for President
on a platform of letting
the South go, basically.
And so Lincoln is struggling
to match the South when it comes to
military leadership, but he does have
other advantages.
For one thing, there are four
times as many free people
in the North as there are in the South.
- [Voiceover] And you made
the point, free people.
- [Kim] Right.
- [Voiceover] Because the
South, as you mentioned,
it has a majority of the
population was not free.
- [Kim] I wouldn't say a
majority of the population,
in many states,
- [Voiceover] In Deep South.
- [Kim] In the Deep South states, right.
But so there are only
about 9,000,000 people
living in the South, and
of those 9,000,000 people
3,500,000 to 4,000,000
of them are enslaved.
So they're not going to be fighting
to continue the institution of slavery.
By contrast, the North
has 22,000,000 people
and it also has a
terrific industrial base.
One of the major cultural differences
between the North and South that leads to
the Civil War is that
the South is primarily
agrarian, and the North
becomes very industrial.
But industry is really helpful in a war.
They've got miles and
miles of railroad tracks
which means that they can move supplies
very quickly, and they also
have hundreds and hundreds
of factories that make it easy
for them to make munitions.
- [Voiceover] This is the middle of the
Industrial Revolution
- [Kim] Right.
- [Voiceover] and an
industrial base matters a lot.
And so what's, given the North's
advantages and the South's advantages,
what's their strategies, how do they try
to play to their strengths?
- [Kim] Right, so the South, they
are basically trying to outlast the North.
They know that they have this territory,
and if the North wants them to come back
into the Union, they're going to have to
conquer this territory.
And even though it's hard to kind of tell,
the territory of the
South is actually larger
than Western Europe.
- [Voiceover] Wow.
- [Kim] So in a way, the
North has a bigger job
to conquer the South than the Allies did
in World War II, to conquer Europe.
So they know that the
North is gonna have to
fight a war to conquer them, whereas
the South just needs to
win the war of waiting.
- [Voiceover] Of attrition.
- [Kim] Yeah, they're
hoping that the North
will get tired of fighting.
- [Voiceover] Fighting
in another person's land,
you're not defending your own land.
- [Kim] Right, and they
know that there are
plenty of whites in the North who don't
care about slavery.
It's not in their..
- [Voiceover] They're
indifferent, what do they care.
- [Kim] Yeah, what do they care, in fact
some people are afraid that
if the slaves are freed
in the South, they're
all gonna come up North
and they're going to compete for labor
with poor white people.
So there are plenty of whites in the North
who have no interest in the slaves
in the South being free, even if that's
not an early war aim of the North.
So the South is hoping that maybe they can
win a couple of really
big battles that show
this isn't gonna be a big war.
- [Voiceover] Or it'd be
so painful for the North
to try to conquer the South, so to speak.
- [Kim] And they're
also trying to show that
they're serious, to an
international audience,
particularly England, because
the South is producing
3/4 of the world's supply
of cotton at this point,
and England is an
industrial nation which is
built in many cases around
textile manufacturing.
So they're hoping that if they show that
they are serious about
their own nationhood
that they're going to win
this war against the North
that England will
intercede on their behalf
to protect their supply of cotton.
- [Voiceover] So this would
be an appeal to England
on purely economic grounds.
- [Kim] Right.
- [Voiceover] Fascinating.
Because England, they didn't have slavery.
- [Kim] No.
- [Voiceover] But purely
economically, at least,
appeal to them.
- [Kim] So on the other
hand, the North's strategy
is what they call "The Anaconda Plan".
And the idea of the Anaconda Plan is that
they are going to squeeze
the South, economically.
What they want to do,
- [Voiceover] Like an anaconda.
- [Kim] Like an anaconda, right.
So they want to blockade
the Atlantic ocean
because they don't want
the South to be able
to sell their cotton to
get money, and they also
don't want the South to be able to buy
the kinds of things that
they're going to need
to make a war happen.
They also want to control
the Mississippi River
cuz that's the real main artery of
commerce in the West.
Anyone who is gonna be
shipping their grain
or their cotton is gonna be shipping it
down the Mississippi to
the port of New Orleans.
So the Union hopes that
if they can basically
surround the South, and make sure nothing
gets in or out, then
eventually they're just
gonna starve to death.
- [Voiceover] This also
goes through the industrial
bays, it can also produce
more ships and etc.
- [Kim] Right, and it takes
them a while to do that,
in fact at the start of
the war, the Union only has
90 ships.
I've heard it compared
to "Five leaky boats".
Right, we're not a naval
power at this point
and so it's gonna take them a while to
build up the kind of naval power they need
to do that, cuz this is
3500 miles of coastline
that they're gonna need to patrol.
- [Voiceover] I'm just
looking at this map, not
getting too much into
details, it looks like
a lot of the battles
are concentrated right
in this Virginia/Maryland area, and then
there's more, it's a
little bit more sparse
but you have a few that
are in the Deep South
and along this Mississippi corridor.
- [Kim] There are two major theaters
of the war.
We'd say the Eastern Theater, and this is
that 100-mile corridor between
Washington and Richmond,
where a huge amount
of the fighting takes place.
It's important to
remember that the capital
of the Confederacy and the capital of the
United States are only 100 miles apart.
- [Voiceover] This capital
is, you can't see it
on this map but it's
someplace in the middle
of Virginia, and then D.C.,
literally, as you mentioned
you said it was 100 miles apart?
- [Kim] Yep.
- [Voiceover] Fascinating.